problema 76 dice en la siguiente figura
tenemos que ave el segmento ave están
gente a la circunferencia del centro o
en el punto a aquí muy bien además la
secante b de secante quiere decir que
corta la circunferencia en dos puntos no
nada más en uno como la tangente
pero bueno dice la secante vd interfecta
la circunferencia del centro o en los
puntos c y de muy bien además la medida
del arco hace es de 70 grados este de
acá y la medida del arco cede es de 110
grados o sea este de acá
este de acá y lo que quieren saber es la
medida del ángulo a abc es decir la
medida de este ángulo que estoy marcando
bueno hay varias formas de resolver este
problema déjame empezar con esta
observemos que aquí ya llevamos 70
grados y si avanzamos ahora hasta d
llevamos otros 110 de modo que desde a
hasta d son 180 grados y por lo tanto a
de es un diámetro como son 180 grados
recorrimos la mitad de la circunferencia
entonces a de diámetro pasa por y por lo
tanto oa oa es un radio de la
circunferencia y así tenemos tenemos que
este ángulo de acá es de 90 grados y
además adb es un triángulo vale porque
de shonko lineales entonces si
tuviéramos alguna forma de encontrar
este ángulo de acá digamos que se llama
x pues pudiéramos encontrar el que nos
piden digamos porque tendría que sumar
90 para que con éste suman 180 bueno
pero este ángulo de acá se conoce como
un ángulo inscrito es decir es un ángulo
en el cual el vértice en el vértice está
sobre la circunferencia
y bueno en las clases de geometría se
enseña que el ángulo el ángulo inscrito
es igual a la mitad del arco que abre es
decir por ejemplo aquí el arco hace mide
70 grados y por lo tanto la medida del
ángulo x es 35 grados 35 grados vale
entonces a partir de aquí ya podemos
calcular y tenemos que ye más 35 grados
es igual a 90 grados por lo que dijimos
antes y así que es igual a 55 grados la
respuesta sería c
vamos a ver otra forma de resolver este
problema vale que es utilizando otra
propiedad esta propiedad dice lo
siguiente si tenemos un ángulo exterior
que corta a la circunferencia en dos
arcos entonces la medida del ángulo
la medida del ángulo es igual a la mitad
de la diferencia de los arcos vale
entonces en este caso el valor de y el
valor de g
sería igual a un medio de la diferencia
del arco a de de la medida del arco a d
él hace con él hace pero como ya vimos
bueno el arco ha de de este lado es de
180 grados entonces acá también es de
180 grados entonces estoy aquí es igual
a un medio de 180 menos 70 menos 70 vale
y esto de aquí sería igual a 110 entre 2
que es igual a 55 y eso está padre con
las matemáticas vimos que esas dos
formas de resolverlo son equivalentes va
bueno pero ojo esto se vale nada más
cuando el ángulo es exterior si el punto
b estuviera aquí adentro entonces en vez
de hacer la diferencia tendríamos que
hacer la suma de ambos arcos y promediar
los bueno entonces vamos a sumarlos y
dividir entre dos pues entonces vamos a
aquí abajo el problema 77 dice en la
siguiente circunferencia la medida del
del arco pr 140 grados o sea este de acá
estoy acá y la medida del ángulo r pq es
de 50 grados este es de 50 grados muy
bien y nos piden la medida del arco pq
pq bueno vamos a utilizar una de las
cosas que aprendimos en el vídeo pasado
tenemos que ir pq es un ángulo inscrito
vale entonces mide la mitad del arco que
abre de esta forma el arco es el doble
de este ángulo y por lo tanto el arco rq
rq mide ciento bueno nada más si en
verdad mide 100
grados ya tenemos la medida del arco pr
del rq y esos dos con el coupé deben de
sumar 360 grados que tiene un círculo
por lo tanto tenemos que que la medida
de él
vamos a poner así ocupe del arco ocupe o
vamos a ponerle pq como nos dicen aquí
entonces pq es igual a 360 grados menos
140 grados menos 100 grados y eso cuánto
es 360 menos yenes 260 menos 140 es 120
entonces la medida del arco pq es igual
a 120 grados respuesta d
muy bien vamos al siguiente problema
problema 78 los vértices del triángulo
abc son igualados 1 b igual a 34 y se
iguala 13 muy bien dice si el triángulo
a veces se trasladó una unidad hacia
abajo o sea las coordenadas en que
tenemos que restarle 1 y 3 unidades
hacia la izquierda o sea las coordenadas
en x tenemos que restarles 3 para crear
el triángulo de f cuáles son las
coordenadas de los vértices de d
efe bueno vamos a hacerlo aquí a la
derecha en color amarillo a ver si
tenemos que hay dos 12.1 s a dónde se va
s se va a d y lo que tenemos que hacer
lo que tenemos que hacer es restar 3 en
la coordenada x aquí queda menos 1 y
restar 1 en la coordenada y aquí
quedaría 0
ahora si vemos las opciones pues
definitivamente ya no puede ser ni este
ni este ni este por lo tanto la
respuesta es d pero vamos a hacer los
otros para asegurarnos que de adeveras
es y que no nos están cambiando las
letras o no nos están haciendo algún
truco vale bueno vamos a hacer b b 3 4
otra vez a la coordenada en x tenemos
que restarle 3 nos quedaría 0 y aquí
tenemos que restarle 1 a la coordenada
en realidad este es el punto es verdad y
punto
entonces aquí hay que restar 1 nos
quedaría 3 va vamos al punto c en el
punto c tenemos el 13 13 y vamos a pasar
al punto f otra vez lo que tenemos que
hacer es restar 3 en esta coordenada nos
queda menos 2 restar 1 en esta y nos
queda 2 entonces vamos a ver si todo
queda bien d es menos 10 ajá
03 ajá efe es menos 2,2 muy bien
entonces definitivamente la respuesta es
de vayamos al problema 79 haber problema
79 si el triángulo abc se rota 180
grados alrededor del origen cuales son
las coordenadas de a prima el punto
correspondiente al vértice atrás la
rotación va entonces aquí tenemos el
triángulo abc y queremos rotar los 180
grados nada más nos interesan las
coordenadas de a pero vamos a rotarlo
todo vale entonces estoy aquí si lo
rotamos 180 grados cae en el -1 1 vale
qué pasa con el vértice b el vértice b
pues a ver estamos avanzando 3 a la
derecha 3 a la derecha y 4 hacia arriba
4 hacia arriba entonces para rotar los
180 grados tenemos que avanzar 3 a la
izquierda 3 a la izquierda y 4 hacia
abajo 4 hacia abajo entonces la
coordenada debe ahora sería las
coordenadas serían menos 3
y finalmente tenemos que el punto a para
llegar a él hay que avanzar 5 para acá y
4 para arriba
entonces para la rotación hay que
avanzar 5 5 a la izquierda voy a llegar
hasta acá y bajar 4 bajar 4 muy bien
entonces las coordenadas de ese punto de
ahí sería menos 5 menos 4 y también
podemos poner las coordenadas de los
otros puntos que ese punto de ahí es
menos 3 - 3 menos cuatro y el de acá es
el menos 1,1 vale menos 1,1 ya nada más
para que quede bonito déjame dibujar el
triángulo abc abc y ahora sí vamos a
responder lo que nos dicen quieren las
coordenadas de a prima es decir de este
punto de acá que serían menos 5 menos 4
la respuesta es ah
muy bien al parecer este fue un problema
pues más como de visualización verdad
eso es lo que lo hace complicado pero
bueno vayamos ahora el problema 80 dice
el trapecio el trapecio voy a agarrar
este color naranja del trapecio abc de
de la figura se traslada a un trapecio a
prima b prima se prima de prima de
acuerdo a la siguiente regla el punto x
coma ya se traslada a x + 3g menos 4 ok
cuáles serán las coordenadas del vértice
se priman ok entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es trasladar se utilizando esta
regla tenemos que se tiene coordenadas
5.151 y por lo tanto utilizando la regla
se prima que coordenadas tendrá pues a x
tenemos que sumarle 35 se va a 8 y allí
tenemos que restarle 41 se va a menos
tres menos 3
entonces las coordenadas del punto
correspondiente hace después de hacer la
traslación son 8,3
3 respuesta de y listo me parece que
terminamos si aquí puse mi mi dibujito
de que ya terminamos con este examen uff
pues estuvo largo pero estuvo padre al
principio me estaba quejando un poco
porque pensaba que era de demasiadas
definiciones pero creo que estuvo bien
después del problema más o menos 20 se
empezaron a poner más bonitos los
problemas de desarrollaban más la
intuición y en general pues sí me gustó
bastante este examen si llegaste hasta
aquí felicidades si entendiste todos los
problemas que resolvimos entonces
ahorita tu geometría está muy muy muy
bien sale bueno nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo aunque bueno ya no va a
ser vídeo de esto pero no importa nos
vemos en algún siguiente vídeo
hasta la próxima